MIT wunderkind Riri Williams is in Namor's sights
in "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever," but would
killing the brilliant student actually achieve
his goals, or just be another needless death?
Warning: Spoilers ahead.
Namor is one of the oldest characters in
Marvel Comics. He's been a hero, a villain,
and pretty much everything in between throughout
that time, so it only makes sense for him to
have shades of gray in his big-screen
debut, "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever."
In the film, Namor is the ruler of Talokan,
an underwater civilization that works hard
to keep its presence a secret from
the rest of the world. Of course,
things go awry when the United States
begins drilling for vibranium in the ocean,
courtesy of a machine originally designed by
Riri Williams. As a result, Namor enlists the
help of Wakanda to track down Riri to bring
her to him so that Talokan can dispose of her.
"I need to know if Wakanda
is an ally or an enemy."
Of course, upon meeting Riri, Shuri and
Okoye realize they can't merely hand her
over to be killed by Namor, and what ensues
is a power struggle between the two nations.
A lot of people needlessly
die because of the conflict,
and it all could've been avoided if Namor had
thought about his plan just a little more.
The Talokan people attack the U.S.
government's vibranium drilling outpost,
disposing of everyone onboard either through a
siren song that makes them drown themselves or
by combat. But that's not enough for Namor; he
wants the Wakandans to track down the scientist
responsible for developing the technology and
deliver them to him so that he can kill her.
The main problem with this plan is that it
does nothing to solve the issue currently
facing Talokan. Namor doesn't want anyone
to know about the empire's existence,
and killing Riri does nothing to prevent that
from happening. Whether Riri lives or dies,
the technology is still out there, and it's
always possible for the government to chalk
up the one attack to a fluke and build another
outpost to drill for more vibranium. In doing so,
they may inadvertently stumble upon Talokan's
existence, and Riri's death will have been
for nothing. Sure, she may be the only one who
understands the tech at the start of the movie,
but by the time Namor's trying to
kill her, the cat is out of the bag.
All Namor would be doing, then, is getting
revenge on someone who inadvertently put
his people in harm's way. But then again, that
does seem to be part of Namor's modus operandi.
Namor's plan may fall apart under scrutiny
for more than a couple of minutes,
but his desire to kill Riri at
least informs viewers about his
character. In both the comics and
the movie, he's a protective ruler.
"Namor loves hispeople.
He's going to protect them, because
to be a ruler, you have to serve the people."
He will do anything to keep his people's
existence a secret from the rest of the
world. Killing Riri may not actually solve his
problems, but it would make himself feel better
to get revenge on someone who threatened his
people, whether it was done intentionally or not.
To look at it from Namor's perspective
for a second, if Riri is still out there,
what's to stop her from inventing something else
that could potentially enable outsiders to locate
Talokan? Or she could continue improving
the technology she designed initially,
causing even more countries to
drill for vibranium. At this point,
Namor is completely unaware that Riri
isn't directly working with the government,
so in his mind, this is just another lackey
who poses a direct threat to his kingdom.
Namor does what he thinks would be best for
his people, but perhaps if he had thought it
through more carefully, he could've saved
both Talokan and Wakanda a lot of trouble.